what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be breaking down the tragic and
twisted backstories of all the upper
demon moons in the demon slayer story
the upper moons are the strongest and
most important villains in demon slayer
after muzon himself and their
backstories range from truly
heartbreaking to completely psychotic
thanks to this video you now have
everything you need to know about their
full backstories right here in one place
so let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our demonstrate
content and you want us to keep it going
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet remember
that subscribing and hitting that bell
is completely free but it's a very real
way of supporting the channel directly
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will contain demonstra manga
spoilers all the information in the
manga is fair game so please proceed
with caution you have been warned let's
start it off with doki and yutaro since
theirs is the first upper moon backstory
that we learn in demon slayer back when
they were human daki and yutaro were
siblings who grew up as part of the
lowest caste of the entertainment
district gyutera was born first and he
was born with a weak body and physical
features that were considered ugly
because of this he was constantly
bullied and abused as a child since he
was dirty smelly and labeled as ugly he
was a massive outcast in the
entertainment district where beauty is
prized above all other things due to the
fact that his mother neglected and
mistreated him deutero was often left to
fend for himself and even had to eat
bugs and insects to survive this further
contributed to his public ostracization
guterro lived a miserable existence and
he felt as if he was born for the sole
purpose of being a punching bag for
others but when his younger sister ume
was born everything changed unlike
gyutaro ume was beautiful and yutaro
decided to do his best to protect her
from the kind of abuse that he had
experienced for his entire life he did
everything in his power to keep his
sister safe he fed her and kept her warm
and thanks to yutaro's superhuman
determination the two of them actually
survived their mother died of a disease
when they were both young and then the
two of them were left to fend for
themselves inside the unforgiving world
of the entertainment district a world
where kids are considered to be nothing
more than an unwanted nuisance keeping
kids alive was just an unwanted expense
to the other inhabitants of the district
so kids were treated more like stray
animals than actual human beings so as
you can imagine dakian yutro had it
rough for quite a while but because of
all the bullying that he had dealt with
for his entire life gyutero became
extremely good at fighting and he
decided to put that skill to work so he
became a debt collector and when someone
owed money and refused to pay gyutera
would show up and collect on the debt he
would also beat down the person whether
they paid the debt or not which led to
him developing a reputation for being
ruthless along with his fighting
abilities he used his appearance that
others found scary as an asset and so he
became a very successful debt collector
things were finally looking up for daki
and yutaro guterre was working as a debt
collector and daki aka ume worked inside
one of the entertainment district houses
but then one night everything changed
that night ume stabbed a samurai in the
eye with a haircut we can assume that
this samurai was a client of hers and
she was instantly punished by being
nearly burned to death there was no
trial here there was no attempt to
figure out why this happened only a
swift and absolutely brutal punishment
when all of this happened yutaro was
away on a job and by the time he
returned his sister was already burned
and on the verge of death gyutera was
beyond himself with grief and he vowed
that he would do anything even kill all
the gods and buddhas if he could just
have his beautiful little sister back
youtube was then also attacked by the
same samurai who had gotten into a fight
with daki and he was injured and almost
killed after the samurai attacked him
from behind however gyutaro managed to
counter-attack and kill both the samurai
and the madam who ran the house the
ducky had worked in and yet even though
he won the fight yutaro and his beloved
sister were both slowly dying from their
injuries as they were lying on the
street in the snow not a single human
being tried to help them as was the case
throughout their entire short lives they
were on their own and not a single
person cared if they lived or died but
that's when upper moon 2 doma showed up
and offered them the opportunity to
become demons gyutero knew that his
sister was dying and since he was
willing to do anything to save her he
agreed to become a demon what's more he
never regretted that decision in fact
according to gyotaro if he had a hundred
other lifetimes he would have always
made the same choice humans never helped
him or his sister they only abused and
tormented them and becoming demons is
what actually saved them from a cruel
and terrifying world after becoming
demons ducky and yutaro rose up through
the ranks until they collectively became
upper moon 6. i don't think it was ever
directly explained why exactly ducky and
yutara were so linked to each other that
they essentially form one collective
body and take up the same demon moon
rank but i personally think that it's
directly related to the way in which
they became demons they were both close
to death when doma approached them but
daki especially was nearly gone and she
wasn't even in a position where she
could fully comprehend what was going on
so it is possible that yutaro agreed to
give up a part of his own body in order
to save ducky since he was determined to
save his sister no matter what it took
maybe this was because daki couldn't
consent at the time so gyutaro had to
make the decision for both of them or
maybe it was because her body was too
damaged by the fire either way they
ended up being intrinsically connected
to each other in their demon forms after
daki and yutoro became the first upper
demon moon to be defeated in over a
century muzon replaced them with the
former demon slayer turned the traitor
kaigaku was an orphan who led a very
tough childhood and he had to become a
thief and steal scraps of food just to
survive at some point he was taken in at
a temple where he lived with eight other
orphans the person who took care of
these orphans was a blind monk by the
name of gyome himejima although they
didn't have much gyome and the orphans
took care of each other and lived
together as a family but one night
kaigaku broke the rules of the temple
and didn't return before dark this rule
about returning home before dark was
very important because the area around
the temple was known for demon activity
because he was out alone at night
kaigaku was captured by a demon in the
forest and he was about to be eaten in
order to save himself kyga could pleaded
with the demon to spare him and in
return for sparing his own life he
promised to lead the demon to the eight
other children at the temple now gyome
had taken precautions against the demons
and he burned wisteria flower incense
every night to keep them away but
kaigaku knew this and he extinguished
the incense so that the demon would be
able to enter the temple four of the
children were taken out instantly and
gyome tried to protect the other four
but since he was blind and not nearly as
strong as he is now three of the
remaining children ran off on their own
instead of hiding behind him and
unfortunately they also fell victim to
the demon when the demon came for gyome
and the final child gyome decided that
he had to fight back despite being a
monk who hated violence he began
fighting the demon with his bare hands
and he just kept on punching him like a
madman until the sun came up and the
demon was killed this is the fight in
which gyome earned that big scar on his
forehead and so kaigaku's betrayal of
his fellow orphans led to the deaths of
seven children but kagaku himself
survived his rough life had led him to
conclude that in order to survive he
must be willing to do literally anything
and what happened to other people did
not matter as long as he came out on top
in the end this extreme and cruel world
view would continue to play a major role
in kaigaku's life years later when
kayaku was a teenager he was taken in by
former thunder hashira jigoro kuajima
and trained to use thunderbreathing
alongside jigoro's other disciple zenit
kaigaku was able to master all of the
thunder breathing forms except for the
first form which is the only form that
zenitsu was able to master overall
kaigaku seemed to be a lot more talented
than zenitsu when it came to being a
demons player and kaigaku felt that he
was far superior to zenitsu he hated
zenitsu because he saw him as weak and
cowardly and he often mocked and bullied
zenitsu during their training when
jigoro declared that he wanted both of
his disciples to become his successors
kagaku was enraged because he thought
that zenith was clearly inferior to him
one day kaigaku came face to face with
upper moon 1 kokushibo as a demon slayer
kagaku had the duty to fight kokushibo
but after sensing kokushibo's
overwhelming strength kaigaku simply
dropped down to his knees and began
begging and pleading with kokushibo to
turn him into a demon once again kaigaku
proved that he had no other values or
principles beyond survival at all cost
as soon as he felt that his life was in
danger he immediately betrayed his duty
as a demonstrator and groveled before a
demon just as he had done as a kid back
when he betrayed his fellow orphans in
order to save his own life kokushipo
agreed to turn kaigaku into a demon and
once he became a demon kaigaku readily
devoured a large number of people in
order to get stronger he was eventually
promoted to the rank of upper moon 6 and
so he became daki and yutaro's
replacement the fact that one of his
disciples went on to become a demon was
so humiliating for jigoro that he
committed seppuku with no second in
order to atone for his disciples crimes
this revelation broke zenitsu's heart
and he vowed to one day defeat kaigaku
alright so after covering the two upper
moon sixes let's talk about upper moon 5
gyoko not much is revealed about his
backstory in the actual manga itself but
we do get some useful information in the
second demon slayer fanbook as a human
his name was managi and he was an
outcast who lived on the outskirts of a
fishing village he was considered to be
a weirdo by everyone since he apparently
collected fish carcasses and did other
weird and creepy things monarchy lost
his parents at a young age they were
both fishermen and on one of their
fishing trips they had an accident and
drowned once the bodies of his mother
and father were uncovered they were
badly decomposed but bizarrely managi
aka gyoko thought that the bodies were
beautiful and he became fascinated by
them one day one of the village children
came to tease gyoko for being so weird
gyoko apparently killed the child and
stuffed the body in a jar when the
child's parents found out they attacked
gyoko stabbed him with a two-pronged
fishing fork and left him to die but
gyoko was stubborn and he clung to life
nearly half a day after being wounded
that's about the time that muzon
happened to come across the injured
gyoko and he was impressed by the fact
that gyoko was stubbornly clinging to
life muzon decided to turn gyoko into a
demon and after that gyoko developed a
taste for a human flesh with an emphasis
on children he seems to despise all
living creatures with the exception of
muzan
next let's talk about upper moon 4 han
tenggu huntengu had been a shameless
liar ever since he was a child and he
constantly made up excuses in his mind
for why he was a victim and everyone
else was a villain in short he had an
insane victim complex and he twisted
facts and made up stories in order to
present himself as a poor innocent man
who had been wronged by everyone else
but despite thinking of himself as a
victim hantengu was actually a ruthless
criminal who did many terrible things
throughout his long life he stole from
people and he also murdered people in
towns and cities across japan
but if he was ever questioned about it
he would vigorously proclaim his
innocence he would go so far as to claim
that he was not responsible for his
crimes because his hands were to blame
implying that he had no control over
them this type of stuff could indicate
that huntengu was mentally disturbed and
unstable or he may have just been a
raging narcissist who believed that he
was entitled to do whatever he pleases
no matter how horrible and so anyone who
stood in his way was a villain who was
somehow victimizing him at least in his
own mind because he was a notorious and
violent criminal hunting would often
change his name and other aspects of his
identity in order to avoid being caught
by the authorities according to the
fanbook he apparently married and had
children multiple times but whenever he
was confronted about his deceptive
nature he would become enraged and take
out his own family he would then repeat
the same cycle over and over again
huntengu was apparently around 87 years
old when he became a demon and this
happened after he was finally captured
by a magistrate and sentenced to death
for his crimes
naturally huntangu kept proclaiming his
innocence over and over again despite
being 100 guilty and it seems that
hunting who might have even partially
believed his own lies because he was
just so deluded as huntengu sat in jail
awaiting execution he was approached by
muzon who offered to turn him into a
demon hantegu agreed and after becoming
a demon he escaped prison and went to
get revenge on the magistrate who had
condemned him to death the magistrate's
dying words to hantengu were that even
though he has escaped for now his past
sins will catch up to him eventually and
he will be punished no matter how hard
he tried to escape that fate huntengu
would eventually get what's coming to
him during the swordsmith village arc
and after that the rank of upper moon 4
was taken over by nakime nakime is
another character whose backstory is
revealed in the second demonstrator fan
book rather than in the manga itself
back when she was human nakime was a
struggling biwa player who was just
barely making ends meet with her music
on top of that her husband was a
compulsive gambler who spent all of
their hard-earned money on his gambling
addiction one night when nakime was
supposed to perform on stage she found
out that her husband had stolen her
dress and gambled it away this was the
last straw for nakime she finally
snapped and killed her husband with a
hammer only a short time after this
incident she was scheduled to perform
nakime walked out on stage in a worn out
and ragged dress and at first the crowd
was skeptical about her because of her
shabby outfit this high pressure
situation combined with the fact that
she had just killed her husband in cold
blood made nakimen nervous and her hands
were shaking as she played the biwa
shockingly the intense nervousness did
not hinder nakima's biwa playing on the
contrary she played better than she had
ever played before and the audience
loved it and demanded an encore everyone
was impressed with nakime and she
received a generous payment for her
incredible performance after this nakimi
realized that the act of killing right
before a performance made her a much
better biwa player and so she decided to
become a serial killer she would seek
out a victim to kill right before a big
performance and every time she did this
she performed beautifully and everyone
loved her she received high praise and
generous compensation and that
encouraged her to continue with her
depraved routine but one day nakima
chose the wrong target while looking for
someone to kill before a big performance
she decided to target muzon needless to
say nakima's attempt to kill muzon
failed miserably but the demon king was
still impressed with nakimen especially
with her ability to track him down so
instead of killing her for trying to end
his own life muzon spared nakime and
offered to turn her into a demon nakime
agreed and she willingly became a demon
and a faithful servant to muzon although
she is not really a fighter she
possesses multiple abilities that are
very useful to muzon including her
ability to control the infinity castle
using the strings of her biwa and also
her ability to spy on others by
releasing multiple eyeballs from her
body that can move on their own and keep
track of her targets
now let's talk about upper moon 3 akaza
one of my favorite villains in demonstr
and someone who just happens to have one
of the best and most heartbreaking
backstories in the entire series akasa's
human name was hakuji and he was born
centuries ago into a poor household in
the slums during a time of extreme
inequality he was so poor that he had to
steal in order to buy medicine for his
sick father and he was arrested multiple
times he was already a repeat offender
by age 11 and he had been marked with
three ring-shaped tattoos on his arms
these tattoos indicated that he was a
convicted criminal and the authorities
threatened that if he was caught
stealing again his next punishment would
be to have his arm cut off after
hakuji's third arrest and severe beating
at the hands of the authorities his
father took his own life so that hakuji
wouldn't have to steal for his sake
his father did not want to take the
medicine if it had to be gained through
illegal means and he didn't want hakuji
to ruin his life because of his
pickpocketing hakuji's father hoped that
after his death hakuji would no longer
feel compelled to break the law and so
he could go on to live an upright and
honorable life but when he realized what
happened hakuji was furious that his
father who did nothing wrong had to take
his own life because there was no legal
means of obtaining his medicine so
hakuji lashed out against the feudal and
extremely hierarchical society of the
time he was eventually banished from edo
the former name of tokyo and he wandered
around japan fighting and causing
trouble he eventually learned how to
fight extremely well and on one occasion
he even beat up seven adults on his own
without even using a weapon after that
fight he was approached by a martial
arts trainer named kaizel kaizo saw
potential in hakuji and after beating
the snot out of him he convinced the
young boy to join his dojo kaizo then
put hakuchi in charge of taking care of
his sick daughter koyuki since hakuji
already had experience taking care of
his sick father he didn't have much
trouble taking on that role after three
years at the dojo hakuji became
extremely close to both kaizo and koyuki
eventually his master asked hakuji to
become his successor and take over the
dojo and koyuki even confessed her
feelings for him and the two of them
were engaged to be married in that
moment hakuji believed that he could
actually start over and live an
honorable life like his father had
always wanted and he would have given
everything to protect his master and
koyuki but one day while hakuji was away
visiting his father's grave people from
a rival dojo who wanted to take over
hakuji's dojo poisoned the well and both
koyuki and kaizo died after drinking the
poisoned water
when hakuji returned and realized what
had happened he completely snapped he
attacked the rival dojo and killed all
67 of its members with his bare hands he
beat them so badly that their bodies
were no longer recognizable and the
carnage was so brutal that the incident
was reported as a demon attack muzon who
knew that he didn't send any demons into
the area was surprised by these reports
so he came to see what was going on for
himself once he found hakuji he injected
his blood into him by force muzon had
already been planning the creation of
the 12 demon moons at this point and he
thought that hakuji aka akaza would be a
great candidate after this occurred
akaza lost his memories and he spent his
life trying to get stronger even though
he had forgotten why the real reason why
he wanted to get stronger was so that he
could protect the people he loved but as
a demon who lost his memories he didn't
even realize that all the people whom he
wanted to protect were already dead
unlike other demons who specifically
agreed to accept muzan's blood hakuji
was never shown specifically agreeing to
be turned into a demon when muzan
approached him hakuji actually tried to
fight him but muzan was too strong so he
forced his hand through hakuji's head
and injected his blood into hakuji to
see if he could handle it hakuji never
said that he wanted to become a demon as
muzan injected blood into him he just
said that he didn't care about anything
anymore and then hakuji lost his
memories and became akaza and being a
demon and fighting was all he knew so
you could argue that unlike many of the
other demons who willingly embraced
muzon akaza was as much a victim as he
was a villain and this is of course what
makes akasa's life and his backstory so
compelling and heartbreaking even after
becoming a demon akaza seemed to hold on
to some shred of his humanity because he
absolutely refused to hurt women muzon
even gave akas a special permission to
spare women because of how adamant akaza
was about not hurting them
next up let's talk about a man who
makassa absolutely despises upper moon
to doma doma was born with insanely rare
rainbow colored eyes and pristine white
hair which made people start worshipping
him as some sort of supernatural being
his own parents convinced themselves
that doma could hear the voices of gods
and so they created the paradise faith
religion around him doma never heard the
voices of gods and he found it
ridiculous that fully grown adults would
believe this stuff and that they would
worship him even though he was just a
clueless kid he thought all these people
were crazy because he himself didn't
even believe in paradise he believed it
was all just fairy tales while doma was
still fairly young his mother found out
that his father was cheating on her with
female followers of the cult she flew
into a rage and stabbed him to death
before taking her own life you might
expect doma to be shocked or sad or
traumatized after this happened but he
wasn't his first thought was that his
mother shouldn't have made such a mess
in the room and that someone now has to
clean up all that blood it's clear that
normal human emotions meant nothing to
doma even before he became a demon doma
always had sociopathic tendencies and
this was only exacerbated once he met
muzon and became a demon at the age of
20. after becoming a demon doma became
immortal and since he never believed in
paradise or an afterlife of any kind
dolma developed the sick belief that
because everyone fears death they could
just live forever through him after he
devours them and because his victims are
no longer afraid of anything or
suffering in any way after they are
eaten doma believes that he is actually
saving them by devouring them for
generations doma used his cult to
attract female followers whom he would
then manipulate and devour and not only
would he do this without any empathy or
remorse but he actually felt good about
doing it because he believed that he was
offering salvation to these women some
15 years after the beginning of the
story inosca's own mother fell victim to
doma inosuka's mother was only around 17
or 18 years old when she decided to
escape from her abusive husband who
would beat her up every day she had no
family and no one to turn to so she
sought help and shelter from the
paradise faith for her and her baby she
had been beaten so badly that she had
gone blind in one eye and her entire
face was swollen but once she healed up
doma thought that she was quite
beautiful her name was kotoha and
inosuke actually looks a lot like her
according to doma he wasn't planning on
devouring inosuka's mother because he
liked having her around but kotoha
realized that doma was secretly
devouring his female followers kotoha
couldn't just stand by and watch this
happen so she confronted doma and tried
to flee the temple doma didn't want her
to reveal the truth about him so he
cornered her in the woods and killed her
right before his mother was killed baby
nosuke fell from a cliff and into a body
of water doma just assumed that the baby
had died but instead the baby survived
and was raised in the wilderness by wild
boars after killing kotoha doma devoured
her according to doma koto has life was
miserable and meaningless but because he
devoured her she could now live forever
inside of him not only was doma
unashamed about what he did to kotoha
but he eventually bragged about it to
enosuke during the infinity castle arc
doma is known for targeting women
especially those with strong and healthy
bodies and he enjoys pretending like the
other upper moons are his precious
comrades but that is certainly not the
case and some of the upper moons such as
akaza genuinely hate him doma was also
the one who killed the shinobu's sister
kanae several years before the beginning
of the demonstrator story
finally we have the strongest upper
demon moon a powerful demon slayer
turned demonic traitor upper moon 1
kokushibo kokushibo was born almost 5
centuries ago and his birth name was
michikatsu tsugikuni michikatsu had a
younger twin brother and the twins name
was yorichi togikuni the same yorichi
who would go on to become the strongest
demon player and the original breath of
the sun user michikatsu and yorichi came
from a prominent samurai family and at
this time during the sengoku period
having twins was actually considered a
bad thing since they are born at
practically the same time which could
result in fights over who will inherit
the father's land and titles to make
things worse this was a very
superstitious time and yorichi was born
with a strange birthmark on his face and
so the father decided that the best
thing to do would be to simply eliminate
lilo yorichi and keep michikatsu
thankfully michikawrichi's mother
refused to let this happen and she
became so angry and aggressive that her
husband agreed to spare yorichi's life
instead of eliminating the younger twin
the family would raise him until he
reached the age of 10 and then they
would send him away to a temple where he
would become a monk due to the fact that
monks usually have to renounce all of
their worldly possessions yorichi would
no longer have any claim to the family's
land and titles and so michikatsu would
be able to succeed his father as the
head of the family without any problems
and so the two twins were raised
completely differently michikatsu was
groomed to be the head of the family and
he had better living quarters better
clothes better food better education and
so on and while michikatsu was busy
preparing himself to one day succeed his
father yurichi became extremely attached
to their mother and he would always
cling to her left side michikatsu felt
bad for his little brother so he would
often sneak into his brother's room in
order to play with him michikatsu wasn't
able to give yorichi any of his
possessions because their father would
notice and get angry so michikatsu gave
his brother a small wooden flute that he
had made himself now yurichi wasn't
exactly a normal child and this further
contributed to his black sheep status
for instance he never smiled not even as
a baby and he didn't even speak until
the age of seven everyone basically
concluded that yorichi must be deaf and
so he would never be able to speak
properly but as it turns out yorichi
wasn't deaf as his brother learned one
day when he was practicing with his
sword in the garden yurichi was just
standing silently behind michikatsu and
watching him but then suddenly he
actually said something he said my
brother is your dream to become the
strongest samurai in the nation
michikatsu was so surprised to hear his
brother actually speaking that he gasped
and dropped his wooden sword yorichi
then said that he also wanted to become
a samurai but michikatsu knew that when
he turned 10 yorichi would be sent to a
temple he was destined to become a monk
not a samurai then michikatsu saw his
brother smile for the very first time
and to him this was an odd and
unsettling sight after this yorichi
started hanging around his brother and
the family's swordsmanship instructor
during their swordsmanship training and
he expressed a desire to learn the way
of the sword the instructor didn't see
any harm in letting yurichi practice
with them so he gave him a wooden
practice sword but after only a few
words of basic instruction the
instructor asked yurichi to try and hit
him michikatsu wasn't expecting anything
much because he himself had never
succeeded in landing a single hit on
their instructor no matter how hard he
tried but then the seven-year-old
yoricci managed to land four strong
blows on their instructor in the blink
of an eye and these four strikes were so
strong that they knocked the instructor
out yurichi's blows didn't break any
bones or cause any permanent damage but
they left massive lumps on the
instructor's body in the places where
the wood had hit following this incident
yorichi stopped saying that he wanted to
become a samurai he hated the feeling of
hitting someone and he didn't want
anything to do with that type of life
but michikatsu was amazed and he wanted
to know the secret behind yurichi's
strength so he kept pushing him to
explain how he became so strong
that is when we learned that even as a
kid yorichi could see into the
transparent world so he could anticipate
his opponent's movements based on the
position of their bones the contractions
of their muscles the flow of their blood
and so on yorichi was also born with
exceptional strength and speed and that
is when michikatsu came to a startling
conclusion all this time he had felt
sorry for his younger brother but the
truth was that yorici was actually much
more talented than he was now michikatsu
worked hard and he had talent so he
certainly made progress and he became
stronger unfortunately for him his
progress was nothing compared to yurichi
who was just an unrivaled genius and
even though yorichi wasn't interested in
the samurai life anymore after the
instructor told their father about
yorichi's unsurpassed talent the father
abruptly changed his mind about his
successor he now wanted the incredibly
strong and talented yorichi to take over
as the head of the family instead of
michikatsu and michikatsu was now forced
to sleep in that small isolated room
where yorichi had been sleeping all this
time to make things even worse
michikatsu was now going to be sent to a
temple when he turned 10 instead of
yorichi which meant that michikatsu's
lifelong dream of becoming a samurai was
now impossible but then one night
yorichi came to tell michikatsu that
their mother had died michikatsu was
shaken by this revelation because he
didn't think that there was anything
wrong with their mother but yorichi just
told them to ask her servant about the
details because he will now be departing
for the temple michikatsu was confused
since yorichi was no longer being forced
to be a monk but yorichi knew that his
father was now planning to send
michikatsu instead of him and so he
decided to go before their father could
do that yorichi said that he will bring
that wooden flute that michikatsu had
made for him so that he could feel like
his older brother was always with him
and then he left michikatsu thought that
flute was poorly made and a piece of
junk and he was surprised to see orichi
acting like it was some sort of treasure
after yorici left michikatsu read his
mother's journal and that's when he
realized that his mother had been
suffering from an illness for years and
that yorichi had sensed it this illness
was affecting the left side of their
mother's body so when yorici was
clinging to that side he wasn't really
clinging he was actually helping to
support her because her body had been
weakened by illness
that is the point at which michikatsu
fully understood that yarichi was far
more observant and talented and
compassionate than him yorichi just
seemed to be good at everything and
because of this michikatsu began to burn
with jealousy he even began to feel
hatred for his own brother because he
just couldn't accept that no matter how
hard he tried yorichi would always be
better than him at everything this is
ironic because back when yorici was
being treated as the black sheep of the
family michikatsu felt sorry for him and
he tried to help him but it seems that
in his own mind michikatsu had also
accepted the idea that he was superior
to yorichi so when the tables turned
then yorichi showed himself to be
superior and then everyone started
treating him as superior michikatsu's
ego couldn't handle it and he began
wishing that his brother had never been
born luckily michikatsu's jealousy
subsided after yurichi disappeared from
his life yorichi had vanished and no one
could locate him so michikatsu's father
had no choice but to make michikatsu his
heir once again ten years passed then
michikatsu settled down and started a
family his days were quiet and boring
and he enjoyed a comfortable and
uneventful life however that comfort was
broken when a demon attacked michikatsu
and his men in the forest the demon
killed michikatsu's men and he was about
to kill him too when an adult yorichi
showed up and took the demon down in an
instant
the moment that michikatsu saw his
brother again he knew that yurichi had
mastered the sword and that he was an
incredible warrior michikatsu's serenity
was destroyed once again and he began to
burn with jealousy yorichi was
unbelievably strong and he had an
impeccable character and michikatsu
decided that he would do anything to
become as strong and as skilled as his
brother michikatsu went so far as to
abandon his family and dedicate his
whole life to following in yorichi's
footsteps and becoming a demon slayer
michikatsu trained under yurichi and he
learned breathing techniques directly
from his brother but none of the other
demon slayers michikatsu included were
able to attain the full extent of
yorichi's power they could never
reproduce the breathing technique that
he used the breath of the sun so yorichi
changed the breathing techniques
slightly as he taught them in order to
make it possible for them to actually
learn and master these techniques that
is how all the many derivatives of sun
breathing emerged and one of those
derivatives was michikatsu's own moon
breathing eventually michikatsu
manifested a demon's layer mark
identical to the one that his brother
was born with and i mean when you take
everything into consideration michikatsu
was an incredibly powerful swordsman and
demonstrator but despite his impressive
strength which was far far above average
mijikatsu still couldn't come even close
to matching yorichi no matter how hard
he trained and no matter how much of his
life he dedicated to getting stronger
michikatsu was simply unable to learn
sun breathing and he could never rival
the superhuman abilities of his brother
and then there was another major problem
all the demon slayers who had managed to
manifest the demon's hair mark began to
die off after reaching the age of 25.
the demon sailor mark allowed the slayer
to unlock more power but in exchange for
that power it drastically reduced the
demon slayer's lifespan michika to
realize that he was going to die without
ever even coming close to achieving his
dream of becoming the strongest samurai
and surpassing his brother and in that
moment of weakness and desperation he
was approached by the crafty demon king
muza muzan told michikatsu that if he
became a demon he could live forever and
he wouldn't have to worry about dying at
the age of 25 he would also have a much
stronger body and he would have all of
eternity to become stronger than yurichi
and so even though he dedicated his
whole life to ridding the world of
demons michikatsu's jealousy got the
best of him he agreed to consume muzan's
blood and become a demon in exchange for
eternal life and super human power that
is when michikatsu tsugikuni became
kokushibo and yet even after 60 years of
being a demon kokushibo still couldn't
overcome yorichi the two brothers faced
off against each other when yorichi was
already in his mid-80s unlike the other
demon slayers who manifested the
demonstra mark yorichi did not die at
the age of 25. this tells us yet again
that yorichi was simply not the average
demon player he was always special since
he was a demon kokushibo didn't age and
he was still at peak strength even
though he should have been like 85 years
old meanwhile yorichi who was not a
demon really was 85 years old and he was
now a frail old man and yet even after
six decades yorichi was still stronger
than kokushibo his technique was so
exceptional that he defeated the demon
kokushibo despite his advanced age
kokushibo was down for the count and at
yorichi's mercy but then yorichi died of
old age before he could strike the
finishing blow against his brother and
so kokushiba lost the battle but he
managed to survive this meant that for
the next 400 years kukushibo had to live
with the knowledge that even as an old
man yurichi was still far stronger than
him
and if all of this wasn't bad enough
when kokushibo cut down yorichi's
lifeless body following yurichi's death
he found that small wooden flute that he
had made for his brother back when they
were children yorichi still treasured
that stupid crappy flute that his twin
brother had made for him all those years
ago and that's despite the fact that
this same brother betrayed the demon
slayers and became a ruthless demon so
not only was yurichi still stronger than
kokushibo even though he was a human in
his 80s and kokushiba was an immortal
demon
but yorichi was also a man of impeccable
character and boundless compassion
something that kokushibo could never
hope to be kokushi was jealousy
destroyed his honor his character and
his compassion and so no matter how many
centuries kokushiba would ultimately get
to live his long-dead brother would
always remain superior to him not only
in strength but in all those categories
as well
and that is it
every upper moon's backstory in demon
slayer explained which was your favorite
backstory out of all the upper moons let
me know down below if you're looking for
a video to watch next i also have a
video that breaks down every hashida's
backstory in demon player link in the
description if you enjoyed this
demonstra video and you want to see more
in the future just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet remember that subscribing
and hitting that notification bell is
free but it's actually a really
important way to directly support the
channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys